Let's go next to our caller from the six,
seven, eight area code who's calling today
from 6, 7, 8.
Hey, David.
My name is John.
I'm from Atlanta.
Big fan of his show.
Thank you.
I didn't want to talk about it.
My, my, my, my, I my thought process in this
upcoming election.
I was a burdensome supporter.
And I'm having a hard time switching over
to giving my support, the Biden for multiple
reasons and all the reasons I've been thinking
about that.
Like we don't talk about is our trust.
Like the biggest thing I've heard throughout
this election.
The most important thing that we must do is
to get real talks.
Get rid of Donald Trump.
And I agree with that.
But my form is that Joe Biden has made it
no secret that if he were elected, he's going
to bring back like that Obama era third wave
centrism as a template for governance in the
White House.
And that sort of ideology is what was I believe
him.
I think it was one of the stars of the Trump
ideology being such an attractive brand.
Will people be disaffected of like third wave
centrism?
So my question is, what is the point of defeating
Donald Trump?
REEVES You're going to bring back the ideology
that helped give us Trump in the first place.
Like what, 2024?
Like, I believe that you did Trump Trump ism
is one the same with the Republican Party.
Won't that cause another, like, right wing
backlash, 50 floors where the Republicans
even more former right nationalists?
So a couple of different things.
There are a couple different things there.
First of all, your argument is a I believe,
more theoretical argument than is relevant
in terms of our decision in November.
It's I don't want to discount what you're
talking about as very important for thinking
about the future direction of the country,
the future direction of the two major parties.
Important conversation to have.
One thing that you're missing from your sort
of framing is that racism was also part of
what took place during Obama's presidency
that coalesced and emboldened some of Donald
Trump's key constituencies.
And I think if we're gonna really talk about
what happened during the Obama administration
that led to Trump, we can't ignore that.
But I want to put that aside just for a second.
If if we can, John, would I want to say to
you, is the following.
The theoretical argument about third way,
send this that.
OK, who do you prefer to choose the next Supreme
Court justice, Trump or Biden?
Just don't think.
Don't overthink it.
BIDEN OK, when it comes to the tax policy,
which candidate has a better tax proposal
if you're familiar with them?
Is it what we've seen Trump do or is it what
Joe Biden has proposed?
Would you like to propose?
OK, Joe Biden supports the Green New Deal
as a framework.
If not in its full scope.
Trump believes climate change is a hoax created
by the Chinese.
Which of those positions is closer to yours?
I guess Biden's right.
OK.
So I could go on with 20 issues.
So for me, it's just much simpler.
We have an emergency.
Bernie Sanders recognizes it.
Noam Chomsky recognizes it.
And for me, the way forward in November is
not about the effect of third way politics
on the future of the it's we actually have
a list of 20 policy issues on which Biden's
better.
For me, it's that simple.
OK.
I understand.
I understand that that's sort of like thinking,
but I was more concerned about like, you know,
just over time, will we like all these games
that we're going to make?
These four years of abiding would just be
like the Lakers.
Like I said before, I just I just I can't
even though Trump may be gone.
I just cannot imagine a Republican Party without
Trump isn't like I think Trumpism has replaced
the car like Reagan era of thought.
I think you're wrong.
And they don't run the Reagan style.
Conservatives are increasingly not what feels
like the core of the modern Republican Party.
OK.
Oh, just resting before I got no other calls,
but I live in Georgia and I'm just saying
that we're like Georgian politics.
But our governor can't is going to like open
up restrictions and state on this Friday.
Yeah.
And if you can consider the information I've
been hearing like some theories that the reason
why camp wants to open up so early.
You know, relatively like what scientists
have been saying is that there's been a astronomical
amount of white unemployment claims in the
state of Georgia.
And we actually may run out because in Georgia,
it works like increased income tax, which
supports that you have to do a cost to mimic.
And with a Republican controlled legislature,
that's like impossible.
So I was thinking maybe go look into that
has seemed like how maybe that might play
into effect.
I think in Georgia, it could be a devastating
set how you're opening up the state before
you hit our apex.
So I just write all was thinking there's a
couple of things going on.
I don't know about the specifics in Georgia,
but there is no question that the reason that
a lot of red state governors want to reopen
sooner than later is if your business is allowed
to be open, then you are going to have a more
difficult time getting P.P. money and other
federal stimulus money if your business is
open.
You are going to be taken off of the unemployment
rolls.
And that is there's no doubt that that is
playing a role in red state governors wanting
to open sooner than later.
Absolutely.
OK.
Thank you, David.
All right, appreciate the call.
Thank you so much.
Really great to hear from you.